i remember saying i love you
and he said i love you too because
chris carver's cousin jefferson can
still remember the parting words of
their final conversation more than a
week after he was shot dead by a police
officer the family are hurting they
still want answers the officer who shot
him suspended a homicide investigation
underway
but they say their need for detail
clarity and evidence is overwhelming we
need a body cam footage and we also want
to see the aerial footage from the
helicopter that was involved in the
chase
you know
we also want a real and a true timeline
of events of what surfaced on that night
their private pain has sparked very
public
a protest last weekend in london
attended by hundreds
now the family are asking people across
the country to join their calls for
justice i know people want to protest
and
show their support and solidarity where
they are you know so we're going to give
we're pretty much going to give them our
blessing you know and our support
but as long as it's peaceful
that campaign began after the 24 year
old was killed by a single shot
following a pursuit by officers who
boxed him in the watchdogger
investigating the case said the vehicle
had been linked to a firearms offense
the day before
it then later revealed he was unarmed
the vehicle not registered to him
the new mech commissioner knows he'll
need to approach incidents like this one
sensitively
as we continue to please local
communities beyond the city center
is to start our journey of reform
we must renew policing by consent
and undetermined under my
commissionership
we will deliver
more trust
less crime and high standards
that is work for the future
but in the present the hurt this family
are feeling is raw our family had to
suffer unimaginable pain
but i know at the end of this there will
be joy you know especially when
justice is served you know so it's
bittersweet and i pray that
he didn't die in vain
shinki maurike sky news